you have to be ready to compete the
whole way through you guys understand
start to finish once you get on the
field
the minimum minimum requirement
is the effort and the competition and
the communication
do your part and do a little bit more to
help your teammates out
guys got that let's go
[Music]
training is back in full swing at the
sporting kansas city academy
but opportunities for players to shine
in competitive action has been hampered
by the pandemic
major league soccer launched mls next in
may a new elite platform for over 9 000
players
at 110 academies across the country the
competition finally kicked off under
detailed health and safety protocols
this fall
with skc facing st louis in their first
match
the way i can i prepare our team for
competitive games
usually the focus is mostly on us and
how we play it's a great gauge to see
where the new kids are where the kids
who've been
here in the academy are and how they
apply
the the information and concepts from
practice the three players for me that
have
improved greatly are
one zaire dyke edward mendy and then
natty clark i think what makes me unique
is i would say mostly
my athletics or like my physique
physical
but also like knowing the game and
reading the game before it happens
and communicating with my teammates and
trying to be
being a leader you guys don't always
have to come to the ball when the center
backs have it
let them drive because he's blocking the
keeper i was born in ethiopia
my mother left and i was uh like one
maybe
but like she only left because it's like
she couldn't like
they couldn't afford it i lived with my
grandma
and i lived with them until i was like
four i was in a
orphanage for almost a year i would say
those were the
toughest moments when
i turned six i got adopted by my family
they gave me an opportunity to succeed
here
my parents got in contact with some guy
that
could find families in ethiopia within
like three or four hours he found them
surprisingly we decided to make a trip
immediately i didn't really know how to
feel at first
i saw my brother and like he started
crying and i started crying
my grandmother and she was just
screaming hallelujah and praying and
crying when i saw her
it was great i couldn't i couldn't
imagine
anything like that i think going through
that and that transfers
to me being a player by just knowing
like that
one opportunity could do a lot for
somebody 90 over the past couple of
years has become
technically very very sound um
he is very very intelligent um reads the
game really well and i think he's just
becoming a more
well-rounded and and total player get in
shape
get your shape go go go go go
intelligence is one of our core
values here at sporting so education is
highly valued
most of our kids are going to end up
going to education route with some of
our
our kids turning pro if they do not turn
pro they
have the option of going to a good
hopefully division one
program that will help them further
their education but also
further their careers that eventually
hopefully some of them can come back and
be pros here just
after they've finished school
my name is betsy maxfield director
of player care soccer is extremely
important you just moved halfway across
the country to play
in our academy but yet you need to be a
well-rounded
person so we take education really
seriously here
audi has really helped us with the
education side with the money we'll be
able to get
tutors and do some act sat prep classes
so ozzie talk to me about virtual school
verse you know face to face which one do
you prefer for me i prefer going to like
actual school um
just interacting with my friends and and
teachers it just
makes school a little more exciting and
you know i just like it more
okay it's amazing what teenagers
feel these days and sometimes it's
impacted by
the pandemic sometimes it's impacted by
social media
the support might be as simple as you're
lending an ear
to talk to them and and understand them
so my role is to take care of all the
distractions and anything that could
happen
off the field so the players can focus
solely on soccer
i'm very excited uh returning to play
games vs st louis especially i'm excited
to play them you know
show them what we got it's a big rivalry
you know they're
across the state from us and you know a
lot of their players you know they've
tried coming on to
our team to join us but you know they
just couldn't make it
i think they just they're always like
wanting to battle against us give it all
they got
i'm always up for the challenge and you
know i'm just ready for them
[Music]
i think the kids get to realize how
important these games are and how you
have to
emotionally lift yourself up to play
against your rivals ah stay high stay
high oz
jay get high jay get higher but it went
here it went here
it went here chris how you helping it
went back it went out wide it went down
and there's nothing they could do george
george george get your good kid gain
space
game space easy odds easy sausage
sausage
[Music]
there's some really really good moments
and there's good moments pressing but it
comes down to the execution of the
actions
listen i want to win too right but i
don't want to win like that
they should have no feeling that they
should be able to play with us honestly
the things that were we're deficient in
is the things that we're deficient in
all week
the focus of the small small tasks and
the small details
really i was just happy to get out there
you know i always like a challenge
it just challenges me to you know think
faster to play quicker
it just helps me out a lot much more we
got the victory so you know
always happy to to win here at home uh
i think the game went well for us as a
group today
we got better as the half went on
and especially in the second half and
took what the coaches said and applied
them in the game
it's been a while since we played so
today was you know the best day i've
spent like the last six months i i think
uh
i did all right because i didn't really
i don't think i did my best
that i could have done but i gave
assists so i think that's one good thing
i've done
in the team for the team i thought they
were good i thought they were effective
gage who sat out a little bit of
practice came in and had
put in a really really good shift and i
think that especially natty did a good
job of affecting the game and affecting
his teammates
i found my role by keep talk keep
communicating to my teammates and
try to keep being the leader all i want
to do is just keep playing
i want to do at the highest level and
against the best players
i've given up everything for soccer i
just got to keep
going hopefully become pro
with match action under their belt
players return to training invigorated
and hoping for more opportunities before
the end of the year
next time on the academy we travel
across the state for a return class with
st louis
as chances to shine become fewer and
decisions around the future of players
move
ever closer